yeah all right welcome to a new video
I'm not sure if it's working properly
because I'm doing this on my vacation
and not on not using my usual equipment
so bear out with me if it's not 100%
perfect um I'm doing um 3 minute uh
session video again this was quite
popular so I'll do this again playing a
couple of three minutes games here maybe
uh for a total video length of half an
hour or something of course game started
yeah I got a game Ellen
beard okay um I'll play the English
defense here with
B6 and um yeah he's gone for an E4 setup
black can try
to play this aggressively here with
F5 trying to get some play on the long
diagonal
immediately but white can um play D3 and
so on it's not
um not a huge problem for
white
okay take
here okay is taking with the Knight this
is
um not really normal
here as it uh should help me because the
file is open
now the question is should
I play Bishop C5 now yeah I guess
so targeting um
F2
quickly okay probably intends to go
Bishop
E3 maybe I can go Knight D4
then
uhhuh
yeah I'll take the chance now to to play
this yeah interesting point
now I guess I grab
it so the question now is if I should
play wow long Castle
mhm interesting decision not not bad or
something just not what I expect
did I think I play
E5 trying
to make this bishop this bishop a bad
Bishop he can yeah he can go
F4 yeah should I allow F5 I'm not
sure should I
take guess I allow
F5
yeah now opening it up here with A6
B5 not sure this is a good
plan B5 yeah this could also be a
weakness not sure but I'd like to have
some play here open up some
files
it's not
clear how otherwise I should should get
some active some active
ideas but these pawns might be targets
also C7 B5 and so on and I'm somewhat
down on the clock I need to speed up
really
okay I want to protect this Pawn D6 with
Rook
A6 yeah he can grab there but this will
open open up even more
lines E4 is E4 is hanging
now time
warning what what what about this oh he
he just Retreats yeah this was a bad
move yeah
check so I'm just a pawn down
right and just have strange pieces here
especially the Rook is um is a
problem yeah I need to protect the six
not much
else yeah just a bad game maybe this B5
plan
boss wasn't really really call
for well I knew this would weaken the
position but uh I
wanted to try to get some
activity I can play F6
now it didn't do
it yeah I know but but Bishop D5
but at this check W what a
game check
yeah just
ugly
yeah this is uh just
lost just a lost end game
check he's terribly
slow not sure what he's doing
here
light forfeits on time yeah he just uh
he was um just terribly slow what can
you do okay next game this was of course
an awful play by
me yeah somehow the long
Castle was um
irritating H uh maybe if 5 wasn't such a
good idea or maybe I should have taken
here F5 is
um is um an annoying move because it
really robs me of any active
plans the bishop on G2 always looks
passive but it uh
somehow protects White's Advanced pawns
here especially E4 and this bishop here
is yeah well it looks active started
doesn't do so much okay next
game nostram is an international Master
this is Cyprus no Lebanon okay okay we
got
um
um I think this is called the btic
defense looks very similar to a
chigorin I'll just try
to play with um yeah simple development
here
yeah he might go Knight
E4 check try to get rid of the pin
immediately yeah black doesn't have any
specific problems
here Knight E4 Knight A5 might be
ideas maybe I should um should go C5
not
sure he could also play Knight H5 now
trying to get the
bishop yeah this is uh the normal move
of
course yeah where to go with the queen
queen B3 Knight
A5 and then he will go
B6 not sure if I like
that
Rook C1 you will also play B6
yeah
yeah the whole C5 idea doesn't really
look look good now
okay let's move this ahead I don't
really like it because I'm so far behind
in
development especially the king is still
on
E1 yeah take here hoping yeah that he
needs to take here because of
C7 okay yeah now let's get some
development
going can go Knight C3 now but this cost
some
time at the expense of um getting my
Bishop
PA uh-huh
okay Knight B2 Maybe
mhm yeah black has some active
Knights
yeah yeah I don't want to take but
uh otherwise he will have a fantastic
night here
really
okay friend arrived
oops okay yeah this threatens a ton of
discoveries Queen B3 Bish Knight D2 is
not great time warning Queen A2 Queen C
C3 is also also
stupid H where do I
go yeah maybe still
here Knight C3 Queen C2 hopefully
doesn't lose material I'm not sure
though it's a very uncomfortable
position I'm not sure if I really can
avoid the draw here I've got just 40
seconds and he's got one and a half
minutes it would be quite
uh quite strange of him to take the draw
though black is obviously fine here H6
okay cover C3
now H
G5 G5 would have been a problem I
think
okay
I really need to speed up
now this this position just just uh
sucks of
course
check
check trading down to this end game is
somewhat
risky time
wise the position I like now with the
Bishops yeah now it is very good for
white
as the B Pawn doesn't move
anymore
check yeah 10 seconds both
players
check
check game drawn yeah this wasn't
exactly
great yeah sorry I just need a second
here yeah let's hope
um gam will be somewhat
better a pretty pretty strong opponent
rating wise open
yamagi
Yagami two three
something okay let's play a Nimo here
and he plays F3 yeah I like castles
here s E4 is a somewhat risky move
now
black opens up um the center quickly
here in this in this
line I'm not um a huge expert but uh I
think um black has got
some some good results
here um not sure do I I think I need to
play Bishop A5 now
it can't be good to to strengthen his
Center okay I take here wants to take D5
M
okay oh no he's going to B5
interesting
check so here I threaten Knight
B3 and I have the idea to go to E4
also
so to E4 now or maybe
F6 opening up the position more even
try F6 don't see a direct technical
problem yeah but I thought if I take
here
now what does he does he
play
okay
yeah I have this s B3 idea he might have
some tactical stuff here on H7
though
okay I could also sacrifice on F3 it's a
it's a a valid idea and then check
here or queen B6 is also also a good
move yeah
had um had some some good good choices
here wasn't sure what's the best but
um all right okay maybe know this
one yeah this move it's
annoying
don't want to trade Queen time
warning Queen
B5 so maybe just playing Bishop D3
then yeah
I somehow I missed my chance
here this was excellent for
black and I don't don't mean a slight
Advantage I mean just really
good but maybe um it's still
okay where is he going with his Queen
now E3 I play C4 this this bishop is
pinned
okay some stupid trick
all I can take you with check
check yeah time is an issue
also need to get the king king
away
I'm not sure what I what what was my was
my mistake
there I really should have punished him
I think this was uh was a very good
position for for
black
this is still nothing for white I
think unless I blend I lose on
time this bishop is bad here I can play
C4 Queen
B6 as an idea just one
idea what is he
doing oh this is a some some connection
issue
yeah most
likely not sure white forfeits due to
disconnection okay yeah this was lucky
but what can what can you
do yeah I'm I'm really I'm really
curious here this position um let's say
this position there should be something
really
I switch on the com quickly I just want
to know or it's some not
working oh Knight
B3 ah I'm I'm just I'm just an idiot on
Bishop H7 of course I can just play King
h8 I don't need to take this is so
silly yeah just Knight B3
wins yeah okay this was easy okay um
next game or do a game request it might
take a
while okay well while I'm waiting for
the game I
can check quickly
here yeah now Bishop A6 still with an
advantage yeah he could have played Rook
F1 okay check game started okay next
game against
Zola okay I'm trying to play
um okay early
A3 I wanted to play an reversed
um sort of Grand Prix
setup yeah okay
cannot think 30 seconds here I just did
almost okay let's go
for a close Sicilian type of position A3
is a somewhat slow move
there not not a big problem of course
but um white usually um tries more um of
a rook B1 B4
plan and then A4 one
move okay sil's got a a very um nice
diagonal
here maybe C6 and Bishop
E6 B7 is just an issue I want
to get some normal development going
here
okay okay let's just defend this
Pawn
an interesting point now should I play
E4 should I stay in the center it's not
easy the C4 Pawn is a weakness I would
like to um play something like Knight C8
to B6 but I think first I need to close
the
diagonal sometimes D5 can be an idea in
such a position but I don't think at the
moment
might be an idea if I go really Knight
C8 yeah but Knight C8 looks um Knight C8
B6 looks U like a good idea still maybe
I should should Retreat this first to to
don't
um that I don't need to worry about D5
with the tempo or Knight f4 on Knight F4
I also would need to retreat um
this piece
anyway
okay it's not doing anything about this
maybe I should I should go
now good go ahead with with this
plan what can he do
C5 yeah maybe I can place
C5 okay went D5 if I go Knight B6
now he can take with the queen yeah
right exchange Knight C4 should be a
great position for
me and if he takes with the pawn I can
just move Queen C7
also
M okay I didn't pay any attention to any
of this okay then I take
D5 I could have taken it um before but
uh not under such uh favorable I think
favorable um
circumstances I could just have taken
the Rook on B2 I'm a complete
time
warning yeah it still should win
material
here maybe I'm not winning
material very silly
just take the rook and it's
over no
okay threaten some discoveries with the
bishop also Knight a
form still fine for me but I can just
take the Rook
here okay
okay I think
this should Retreat to allow Knight
C4 the Knight is just good here
attacking A3 and so on maybe also to
E5 and he somehow doesn't speed
up
okay
should I grab even another
Pawn no he most likely um lose some
time
okay it's not easy from a technical
point of view in this
time
white forfeits on
time yeah don't ask me why I didn't take
this this bloody Rook on
B2 I can take it now I didn't and now
I'm not sure if I still still win
material here I could take U C3 now and
Bishop C4 winning the
exchange but um yeah I saw this even but
I wasn't so sure if this is good and I
thought this would be better but now I'm
winning nothing yeah okay not one of the
best sessions here okay next game game
started um let's play one E4 for a
change oh
the or whatever it
pronounced one of those open
uh I know nothing
about
C6 not
sure okay I know this fianchetto is
possible is this is this a problem I
have Knight A3
yeah Knight A3 is not not a happy move
but also not a problem yeah I don't want
to exchange here so
much black is um
usually having some um disadvantage in
space so don't want to change to
exchange too many
pieces yeah Knight
D3 okay what can you do maybe um I could
have played some sophisticated maneuver
to prevent this
but
wow isn't C6 now
not
lost B6 is a really a weird
move now this whole setup makes a
perfect
sense yeah
okay maybe I should should first
Exchange some pieces
check um before I take the
exchange and what now D5
maybe
D5 using this pin for a
moment of The Rook Rook with is the
queen
yeah yeah F4 looks uh somewhat
weakening so what can you
do
I don't really see
um any concrete attack
here I still have
um have enough defensive
pieces against those Bishop F3 kind of
stuff yeah going go KN Queen to F3 is
also not possible at the moment
Queen D5 also not
possible Rook E8 I just
take and then
D7
okay time
warning Bishop Bishop I can take and
queen E8 Rook takes Queen E8 check Rook
D7 should wi material
really still still not so
easy it's not clear if I'm really
threatening
anything because of uh the queen F3
resource
he takes with the
bishop he should be in a in pin
then Queen D4 was my
intention ah Rook
E8 and can take in Queen E4 okay
okay Rook d8 Queen
F3 just
ridiculous but um seems to
work Rook d8 Queen
F3 yeah
silly
check
check yeah I need to win on time black
forfeits on time yeah I really should
have won easily on position but somehow
he found this nice trick
here yeah but he found this trick I can
maybe just play whatever Rook D1 or
something and just
win yeah no
idea this kind of uh exchange wins are
sometimes tricky with this bishop yeah
of course F4 was somewhat risky
okay another
game
started E4 okay let's play
E5 in uh honor of the repertoire
series Bishop
B5 okay let's play okay exchanging on on
C6
The Exchange
variation okay I'll play
some new line for me never tried this
but it's interesting this is um a pawn
sacrifice after G4 white um didn't
accept
it now um I can play F6 and even C5 to
secure the center
and white has nothing
white really needs to accept this Pawn
otherwise it's just uh it's just nothing
for
him okay let's just think a minute here
Rook B8 should I play this or
B6 it's also um perfectly normal
move okay let's play B6 also secure
bring the C5 Pawn once
again yeah I cannot Castle because of
this discovery so need to retreat the
bishop okay he's not taking
him
yeah we can try to uh bring a knight to
F5 it doesn't really um bring any huge
benefits but you can
try okay now I'll chase away the Knight
or or
this yeah but um it's not doing much
really can play Bishop E6 next move and
then this Knight has to retreat
or I don't know what what you should
do
yeah yeah it's just a relatively dull
position
all
right check it's hard to um to do
anything active
here the pawn structure is um somewhat
symmetrical
and
um really hard to make uh any progress
somewhere could try to infiltrate with
the queen here A7 but he might have some
count to
play yeah I can try this but um it
doesn't do much
really okay
maybe he can exchange a knight
F5 I was intending after capturing
Bishop Bishop B1 D3 was my idea but I
didn't pay any attention here he sort of
played me to sleep here with this with
this
annoying
and also this one is just just also
hanging yeah of course uh this was
entirely
unnecessary to get in trouble
here can just play anything not not
this yeah um Knight C4 is Mya if he
takes here Knight C4 B2
check
guys
it's 92 coming now I most likely I will
lose on time because he B is just awful
technically
check
yeah dead
draw draw
offered draw offered game drawn yeah
that's fair play but uh I'm not sure I
even might have won this with a couple
of pre moves yeah Queen A2 was just
uh just too quickly played Just
blundering
D6 of course Queen B1 is not exactly the
move to uh to
um yeah makes you shake in your boots I
can just play G6 or something prevent
Knight F5 and it's just an even
position not much else okay one more
game game
started is up
Tron play C4 for a
change uhhuh he's grabbing a
pawn white needs to quickly um open up
the queen set
here uhhuh very
early before
it's a good idea to prevent black from
playing
A5 often A6 can be a very disturbing
move
okay should I go immediately Knight E5
sometimes trying to play A6 directly
let's play in a direct fashion
here why threatens not now A6 and uh
yeah Black's Queen side just
explodes Queen D4 have Bishop
B2 okay tries to prevent this but this
allows E4 and
D4 trying to um open up the center D4
D5 yeah not D4 I don't mind if you take
this
okay Bishop E3 or Bishop B2
difficult yeah this is impossible to
decide really in a in a game with such a
Time control white has a um a great
compensation
anyway but it's hard to say
um so such details like the bishop
placement you cannot figure out in in
such um such short short
time okay D4 he wants
to
attack I guess D5 is not possible
so should I protect this
simply it's not ideal I don't want to
play Knight
F3
okay Knight D Knight C3 I can just take
because B7
hangs
okay back
again now I'm threatening something on
A6 or
C6 not sure if it's a real threat but um
there are
possibilities maybe also Queen A4 an
idea but Queen
A4 has the disadvantage of releasing
pressure from E6 because F6 could be an
idea kick this Knight at the moment I
can just take
here okay maybe I can just increase the
pressure on the C6
Pawn trying to catch up a bit on the
clock
also yeah I just saw this bit too late
time
warning
okay C6
now A6 is is the
issue now maybe bishop B5
Bishop
B5
check didn't didn't see this
check unfortunately ah now the Knight is
hanging okay I'm
completely completely overlooking
everything
now it's a good idea to stop the session
after this game of course white was just
winning I think
and now he's got this uh silly
counterplay with the
bishop counter play is it's a nice
word it's just winning I
guess yeah don't see a
move Queen
F3 yeah can
resign white
resigns yeah this is of course was
entirely
unnecessary white white should be just
winning here in this
position a bishop takes
yeah yeah of course Bishop takes and
black
resigns I'm not sure I I played this
because uh I didn't really appreciate
Rook
takes Bishop D2 and it's just over
completely ridiculous position position
of Black's Queen side Knight on A6
Bishop on B7 white just
wins and that after this is not entirely
clear and of course I didn't see the
check
check this uh this is awful but I cannot
take on C6 Queen C6 and it's the same
deal made on H1 so um I I just I just
didn't didn't appreciate this move at
all so so really silly
yeah okay this was a almost 50 minute
long session I didn't play really well
but I hope it was entertaining and
instructive at some points yeah thanks
for watching and um yeah talk to you
soon in a new
video